次のセクション ２部ですけどね
これは理性って何ですかと
で 感情のリストの中に理解能力も知恵も入ってるんだから
わざわざ理性って何や？っていう問題が出てくるんです
これは因縁法則のことなんです
理性っていうのは データを集めていけばデータの倉庫になるだけでしょう
人間っていうのは あれもこれもデータだけ知識だけ集めるんですけど
ただの倉庫です 人はデータの関連性を発見して様々な公式を作るんです
この公式が正しければ
未だ知らないものにすぎても
まだデータが取れないものにすぎても簡単にわかるんです
これは我々の知識世界でしょ
人はたくさん本を読んでいるんだからといって知識人じゃないでしょ
時々読んで辞書を丸ごと暗記するんでしょうに
私も結構知っていたんだからね
もう大学にいた時は ある子はもう自慢するんです
私はもう辞書を丸ごと暗記したんだよ
それで3冊を買うはめになりましたと
暗記したいと潰れちゃって
また買って それももう潰れちゃって
やっと大学に入っているんですけど
私はそうすごいねと言ったんですけどね
辞書は全然暗記していない
私は英語で英語は書けられる
書けるし 喋るし使えるし
研究も何でもかんでも英語でやっているし
あの人に何かえーと えーとですね
すごくえらく苦労するんです
ちょっとしたことを喋るために
何これ？と だから暗記したって言ってもね
これ 知恵も知識でも何でもないんです
あのデータどう使うのかと
関連性がね 大事なんです
で それで研究者研究論文をする
書くということは 自分が調べたデータの関連性を発見して
それで公式を作るんですよ
これが論文の結論になるんです
こうなって こうなって
こういうわけでこうなって
だからこういうことです
こういう公式発見すると
知らないことまで知ることができる
例えば この宇宙のことは宇宙科学でよく喋っているでしょうに
全然行ってもないくせに
あれ どうやって言うんでしょうかね
地球以外何も知らないのに
宇宙は膨張しているんだぞとか
どうやって言えるんでしょうかね
ある公式があるんでしょう
もう一つじゃなくて たくさん
例えば宇宙は膨張しているというリコス
単純な公式でしょ あのホーキングさんがそこは一般人に分かりやすく書いてますけどね
例えばこちら立っていると
車が遠くから自分の方に来る時の音と
自分から車が出ている時の音はどうなるんでしょうか
と で この波長の違うんですね
出ていく時と来る時の
だからそこで光の波長を見ると出ていくような波長になって
あ なるほど だから膨張しているんだ
全然知らないことで推論するんですよ
だから公式正しければ結論も正しいんです
例えば三角形の面積を計算する公式を知るならば
どのような三角形の面積も正しく知ることができるでしょうに
変化するすべての物事の公式は因縁論です
それで すべての心であろうが感情であろうが物質であろうが
すべて変化する 変化する公式っていうのは因縁論なんです
だから 科学者発見したすべての公式よりも
もう究極的な公式なんです
それが 因縁律で説明できないものは一切なし
因果律の公式は至って心配だから
我々はできるだけたくさんデータを収集すれば良いんです
因果法則の公式っていうのはものすごいシンプル
これがあるからこれがある
これがない時はこれがない
これが生まれるとこれが生まれる
これが消えるとこれも消えるという
それだけ それだけでは何もわかりませんよ
それでデータ収集するんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想とはデータ収集なんですよ
命って何で何であろうかとデータ収集するとたくさんデータが出てくるので
それは公式に当てはめるんです
これがあるからこれがある
これがない時はこれがないと当てはめたところで下がります
因果法則なく解脱はできません
なんで長い長い時間瞑想させるのかというと
十分データを取ってくださいと
自分に関わるデータを取って見てみなさいと
自分でも公式を発見するんです
発見した瞬間で悟りということになるんです
第1番目の悟りを説明する場合は
ヤンキンジサムデーダンマンサッバンタニロダダンマンということをわかったんだと
生じる法があるならば
全て滅する法でもあると
それをわかったら第一の悟りなんです
ドルカなんです 隠してない
全部もう前もって言ってますけどね
でもお釈迦様がやっぱり自分でそれを発見してほしいんです
理性を発展するということではありません
だから理性の発展というのはないんです
感情全感情の発展はあります
それをもうすごい均等になるまで育てないと
理性って別に発展ともなる
ただの公式なんです 当てはまるかないかだけのことなんです
俗世間で基本を学んだらたくさん経験しなさいというようなものです
教習所で運転の基本を学ぶでしょうに
それでプロになりませんでしょう
それから経験すればいいんです
毎日運転してみれば プロになるんです
だから理性理性っていうのは基本だけのことで
それ別に成長 発展ではなくて
データたくさん集めて経験を深めなさいと
経験はものを言うんだからね
仏教の場合は 全感情を育てることは経験を深めることです
そこで我々は全感情を育てていくことによって
たくさん経験を深めて深めていくんです
それにあの公式を公式を当てはめるんです
それで悟ってしまうんです
因果公式に沿って全感情を向上すると解脱するんです
悟り 法僧と法則と理性っていうのはそんなもんなんです
だから理性についてすごい長い時間喋る必要はないんです
感情についてすごい時間かかっちゃったんですけど
だから結局は理性と感情のバランスではないんです
全感情のバランスであって
理性はある一つのコンスタント
あの数学では言ってるでしょ
科学でもあの あるものはコンスタントでずっと続けるという
変わらない一つの条件という感じ
ベリァブルではなくてコンスタントなんですね
まあ日本語の言葉を知らないんだから言えませんだけど
まあ一応え 定数ですね
はいはい だから理性というのはその定数みたいなものなんです
ウェイリャーブルは我々が育てるべき感情なんです
だからあまりこの理性と感情のバランスというわけじゃないんです
全感情のバランスと理性
理性は定数です ん？ 方程式と変数って言った方がいいんじゃないですか
方程式  まあとにかくこんな役に立たないんですから
難しい話になってもね
わからないみたい ですから
俗世間の話をします バランスのある人間
難しい話はさておいて
簡単なことだけします
まず 感情の繰り返しを覚えておきましょう
感情こそが生きるエネルギー
しつけしてもなくても人は生きている
感情があるからね 人はもうしつけあっても
文化あっても 教育があってもなくてもちゃんと生きている
他の生命も感情のパワーで生きている
人間だけじゃないんです
これをなくすことはできません
生きているエネルギーなくすことできないでしょうに
毒の流れを感動の流れにするんです
だから 今の生きてるエネルギーは毒の流れなんですね
それを感動の流れにするんです
では どうしましょうか？貪瞋痴の流れを清らかなエネルギーにするためにどうしましょうか？貪瞋痴ではなく
慈しみを生きる衝動にするんです
これだったらもうわかってるでしょうに
貪瞋痴はわかります でも布団婦人プチはわかりません
だったら慈しみぐらいわかるでしょうに
それをわからないといえば
もうお手上げ 私に文句言ってても意味がないんです
それ以上はもうできない
慈しみぐらい 優しさぐらい
そこをエネルギーにするんです
人のこと 生命のこと 平等に区別差別なく心配する人間になるんです
生命のことは人のこと
平等に区別差別なく心配だと
心配するという単語を知ってるでしょ？そこから始める
みんなのこと心配しなさいよと
こうすっごいエネルギー感じますよ
ゴキブリのこともアリのことも虫のことも心配してるようになるとすごいエネルギー
他人の役に立つことが正しい人生だと思う
人間でどう生きていればいいでしょうか？と
難しい問題ですね 簡単です
答えは 人の役に立て それでは
シンプルでしょう これが人間の道ですと
犬猫の道とは違うんだよ
犬猫の役に立っているのにね
結局は 自分の日々向上しなくてはならない存在であると覚えておくんです
我輩は完全じゃあではなくて
私も毎日毎日やっぱり向上しなくちゃいけないなとかね
よく覚えておくんです
忘れないで それだけで向上します
毎日毎日 まあやっぱりもうちょこっと良くならなくちゃ
だから実践的にはそれほど難しくないんですよ
論理は難しいんでしょうね
だから論理の世界はだいたいお釈迦様は出家弟子たちに徹底的に教えたんであって
これっていうのはそうそう接する智慧の世界だよと
でも一般人に喋れば そんな言わなくてもいいよ
みんな経験しますよ ということで
この一般的にはそんなもんです
喜びを感じるんです 充実感を感じるんです
だから私は今日書き忘れちゃったんですけど
よくヒューマーというか
楽しみ 冗談的な生き方をした方がいいんです
何があってもちょこっと笑って笑っちゃえば
だから社長に怒鳴られたっても
そのあとちょこっと何か冗談言っちゃうと
ほとんど問題が解決するんでしょうね
そこがこの喜び 充実感を感じて生きることなんです
自分も楽しく他も楽しくなる生き方をする
生きる上で自分も楽しく生きる
他人も楽しくする だからこんな生きることは苦だから
苦しいんだからね これがわざとやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
自分がそうじしたら楽しくないんです
だから成長するんです
人間にできない 理解も不可能な生き方に挑戦している自分に対して
よく頑張っていると褒めてあげるんです
これがないんだから 5
回守りたいんだけども
人間関係だからいくつか破ってもよろしいでしょうか？と私に聞くんです
な 話にならない これは初めからもう一般人にできないことをやっているんだからすごいことでしょう
嘘をつかないと言ったっても
酒飲むのをやめたと言ったってもね
相当な大変な挑戦でしょうに
自分一人なら酒はやめられますけど
社会関係もありますから
社会は酒飲むほど信頼できないと思っているでしょうし
なぜならば 酒飲んだらアホでグサッと相手バカで信頼できなくて
何やってるかわからないんだから信頼してくるんです
犯罪は起こすわ だからそういう社会から違うことやってますからね
自分を褒めてあげたらどうですかね
頑張ってるんだ 理性の育ち方
感情があった 感情では理性もちょこちょこ育てなくちゃいけないんですよ
これ 今のは公式を理解することだから
まあ例えば三角形の面積を取るということは
まあ公式だけ暗記しちゃうと何か気持ち悪いんでしょうね
だからまず自分で先生から教えてもらって
あの まあ長方形だったらこういう風にするでしょ
長方形だったら この あの90のあれね
あのあれ あの 2つかければ面積であると
それで半分になったら半分だからこちらの半分でしょうと
ということは はい あの90度のあれは英語だったらハイって言うんですけど
ハイエンドベース そこでハイとベースというね
HB かけて半分でしょうね
あ なるほど わかったわかったと
そうやってあの公式をわかった方が自分のものになるんです
それから忘れません だから我々は理性育てるためね
何をやってもこれ役に立つと自問してみるんです
役に立つ これはってきたら因果法則わかるんでしょう
それだけじゃない 正しい方向の因果法則
例えばね もう拳銃を訓練する
それで役に立ちます なんで人を殺せると
それが正しい方向じゃないでしょうに
だから何をやっても何か役に立つということを自分に頭に入れておけば
頭良くなります 何をやってもより早く期待する結果を出せるのかと調べ
自分の仕事をのろくてもいいんです
しかし もっと早く結果出せる方法あるのかとかね
ちょっと調べると 答えは書いてました
仕事の障害を ん？見つかることですか？なんでこれ入っていますかね
だから何か仕事するでしょうね
この仕事を早くもうのろくて早くやらなくてもいいんです
あまりにも早くやろうと思っちゃうと
欲が出てきて 焦りが出てきて失敗するんだから
そうではなくて この仕事に何が邪魔でしょうか
何が障害でしょうかと見つけることです
あ これが障害だと分かったら
そこを削除すれば早いんです
結果は ニュースを見ても
勉強する時でも なぜこのようになったのかと
その答えを探すのです
ただ口を開けてニュース見るんじゃないんです
あ そうか なんでこうなったんでしょうかね
あ こういうことだっていうか
いう風に頭そば持ってみるんです
世の中は議論だらけです
様々な問題に関係ある人々は一応結論を出す
一方ですか え？一方 だからいろんな問題に関わって
政治家は政治問題に関わっているわ
外務省人は外交関係に関わっているわ
医者は医療に関わっているわとか
それぞれいろんな世界に
みんないろんなことに関わってますけど
でもどんな世界でも異論だらけなんですよ
うまくいかない いろんな人がいろんな意見持っていて
それでそれなりの人は何か解決方法を出すんです
結論っていうのは 自分の
憎しみなく 偏ることなく
先入観なく 別な結論 別な答えを出せないのかとシミュレーションゲームをやるんです
まあ何でもいいでしょうね
例えばどこかでどこかでこうこういう風に入りましたと
それで じゃあ私ならどうするのかと
その時は偏ったらダメです
でも関係ないんだから
別に 先入観でも何でもなく
ちょっとシミュレーションしてみるんです
結構頭が良くなる方法なんです
これで理性の達人になるんです
大体自分に関係ないものについていろいろシミュレーションやると結構頭が良くなります
自分が関わっているものでは頭が動かないんですよ
自分の子供のことなら全然頭が回転してくれないんです
悪い結論ばっかり出すんです
やったらいけないこと
客観的に他人のことだったらよく見えたりするでしょ
それよりシミュレーションゲームやってみて
答えこれやと分かっちゃうと
もうそれで何のことなく
自分についてやっても同じことが分かります
では終わり  うん